I have difficulty ascribing reasons to
current behaviors because I think we
just don't know why who knows I know
that I am this way I know that I behave
in these ways in these conditions they
are what they are and I think a lot of
people I'm not saying this good or bad
I'm just saying I have observed that
many people will create stories to
justify well I never got chocolate as a
kid and that's why I eat chocolate now
I'm like well maybe you just black
chocolate maybe it has nothing to do
with the fact you didn't have this kid
maybe if you had it as a kid you'd still
eat a lot of chocolate it has nothing to
do with that and so people use
circumstances to explain current reality
as though it's a reason for rather than
just like accepting it for what it is
which is I just am this way